it was 1944
our orders were to liberate the italian
city of gita
taking the beach was our first objective
shells were raining down on us as we
rushed toward the german fortifications
the german bunkers were overlooking the
entire beach
once we were in range we hit them from
both sides
once the first bunker collapsed the
defense opened up
after securing the beach we were told to
take a nearby flak 88
blowing up the artillery was the only
way we could hold our position
we accomplished our mission but
this long day had just begun
while we led the main front they dropped
in paratroopers to stop any german
reinforcements
they never saw them coming
they never stood a chance
the outskirts of the city were now ours
we set up a forward base urgently
building a triage center for the wounded
we rallied together and prepared for the
final assault
we made our way toward the city square
they were expecting us
but we were one step ahead of them even
with the help from the british
we knew this was going to be an uphill
fight
german troops were gathered in the main
square we didn't expect that level of
resistance
under heavy fire buildings collapsing
around us and for a while
they had the upper hand but we kept on
pushing
we managed to hold the position long
enough for air support to arrive
the city was ours but our fight in italy
had only just begun
[Music]
you